former British Marine is to be braving  treacherous waters to become the first  blind man to complete a boat race across  the Pacific Ocean  Steve sparks and his partner Mick Dosan  are rowing more than 2400 miles from  Monterey California to Waikiki Hawaii  the two are still about 150 miles away  from their final destination they're  getting ready for hurricane lane as it  approaches the Hawaiian Islands Sparks  spoke to us from his boat about the  historic feat and how he's preparing for  the dangerous weather  just hang in there whether such a person  can see that the space receiver you can  see the rolling rains coming at you I  can find in fact there and I'm not going  riding a bucking bronco you can see more  of that interview tonight on the CBS  Evening News with Jeff Glor